في الاثناء قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان 29 من قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي سقطوا
بنيران زملائهم وحوادث عمليات حسب تعبيرها
ووفقا للتفاصيل التي نقلتها صحيفه هرتس
الاسرائيليه فان 8 منهم قتلوا بنيران
متبادله مع زملائهم منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه البريه بينما سقط 11 جنديا اخرون
بحوادث ياتيه ونيران عشوائيه
معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد كيف التفاعل في اسرائيل مع
هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت مع بدايه العام
الجديد وايضا نريد منك تفاصيل اكثر حول
هذا الاعلان الاسرائيلي عن سقوط
29 من الجيش الاسرائيلي بنيران
صديقه هذا الاعلان من جانب الجيش
الاسرائيلي يشير الى حاله باك التي
يواجهها الجنود الاسرائيليون الذين دخلوا
الى قطاع غزه ضمن العمليه البريه في ال6
من اكتوبر الماضي 29 جنديا وضابطا قتلوا
بما يوصف بنيران صديقه بينهم 18 قتلوا في
عمليات اطلاق متبادله بما فيها قصف من
دبابه وهذا مؤشر على ان الجنود
الاسرائيليين داخل القطاع يعيشون حاله من
الرعب وحاله من الارتباك الشديد ان ياتي
الجيش الاسرائيلي ويعلن عن ذلك في بيان
رسمي صباح هذا اليوم هو محاوله من جانبه
ايضا للاشاره للشارع الاسرائيلي عن ضراوه
القتال وعن واقع الحال في هذه الحرب
بالنسبه للجنود الاسرائيليين 29 من بين
178 قتلوا منذ بدايه الحرب البريه او
الاجتياح البري الاسرائيلي يعتبر عددا
هائلا وكبيرا جدا وان هذه القوات كانت في
بعض الاحيان بسبب ارتباكها تشتبك مع نفسها
وتطلق النيران لذلك قتل هذا العدد الكبير
من الجنود وهو ما يشير في نظرهم الى حاله
الارباك يضاف الى هذا كله الاعداد الكبيره
من الاصابات ايضا التي وقعت منذ بدايه
الحرب البريه والمتواصل والتي وصلت الى
المستشفيات تحديدا مستشفى سروك في بئر
السبع وبرازيلي في عسقلان كونهما الاقرب
الى منطقه قطاع غزه وان كان العديد من
الجرحى قد نقلوا ايضا الى مستشفيات في قلب
اسرائيل في القدس الغربيه وفي منطقه تل
ابيب منطقه تل ابيب التي كانت هدفا في
منتصف الليل مع دخول العام الجديد لحظاته
الاولى كانت هدفا لدفعه من الصواريخ اطلقت
من قطاع غزه قدرت بنحو 20 صاروخا اطلق لكن
اهميه ذلك في نظر الاسرائيليين انفس
ليس في مجرد المنطقه التي استهدفت وهي
منطقه تلبيب الكبرى وانما في قدره
المقاومه الفلسطينيه على اطلاق هذه الدفعه
من الصواريخ والى مديات بعيده في ظل الحرب
المسعوره التي تشنها اسرائيل سواء في
شمالي القطاع او في جنوبه وفي جنوبه على
وجه الخصوص من الواضح ان هناك قوات
اسرائيليه هائله سبعه الويه تحارب في هذه
منطقه بالاضافه لسلاح الجو وكذلك للمدفعيه
والدبابات والتصوير سواء في الاقمار
الصناعيه او ما تقوم به ايضا طائرات
استطلاع وتصوير امريكيه وبريطانيه كان قد
كشف عنها في مرات سابقه ورغم هذا كله ورغم
التوغل الاسرائيلي كانت ال المقاومه
وكتائب القسام على وجه الخصوص قادره على
اطلاق مثل هذه الصواريخ وان كان وقعها
النفسي اقوى بكثير من قدرتها التدميريه
لكن احدثت حاله من الارباك في الجانب
الاسرائيلي على المستويين الشعبي الشارع
الاسرائيلي وعلى المستوى العسكري والسياسي
واعتبروا ان هذا مؤشر على ان كتائب القسام
تملك ترسانه اضافيه حسب تعبيرهم للصواريخ
وانها قادره على توجيه ضربات من هذا
القبيل ايضا في قادم الايام رغم ضراوه
القتال وجاء هذا في وقت كان فيه مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي مجتمعا فيما يعرف بالكر
وهي مجمع قياده الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه
ووزاره الدفاع ورئاسه الوزراء في تل ابيب
هذا الاجتماع الذي كان يبحث كان من
المفترض ان يبحث اليوم التالي للحرب لكن
نتنياهو عاد مره جديده ومنع بحث هذه
القضيه وردخ بذلك لتهديدات وزرائه
المتطرفين واكتفى ببحث مواضيع تتعلق في
قضيه ابرام صفقه اسرى جديده لكن ليس هناك
ما ي الى وج تقدم او اختراق بهذا الخوص
وليد عمري مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من
رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك